So, here they are. These are the tests from the provided question. And that was
called test as well, so I'm going to rename my test mytest, and let's see now
if we pass all the tests. And we do, so I'm fairly confident my code is correct now.
If we wanted it to be faster, there's lots of things we could do better
than this really simple, stupid approach of just going day by day. But in terms
of getting correct code, the simple approach had a lot of advantages. So I'll
encourage you if you want to extend this as another programming exercise to try
to make it faster. But in this case we're pretty happy with this. The other
thing I'll mention if this were not a programming exercise. Python has built in
types for managing dates. And that would make your life a lot easier to use
those. There are lots and lots of different ways to solve this problem. Some of
you may have come up with better ways than the one that I did. Certainly most of
you probably came up with more efficient ways. If you have an interesting way of
solving I would encourage you to post that for discussion on the class forum.